con el 3 de noviembre cada vez más cerca
tanto republicanos como demócratas están
luchando para presentar sus argumentos
finales a los votantes relegado en las
encuestas el presidente de donald trump
continúa su campaña firmando calabazas y
reuniéndose con una multitud sin
distanciamiento social durante una
visita sorpresa a un número de manzanas
en maine un estado clave a principios
del domingo habló en un mitin de new
hampshire centrándose en las propuestas
económicas de su rival joe biden del
solar
esta elección es una elección entre una
recuperación trump y lo llama una super
recuperación trump porque eso es lo que
está pasando y una depresión de bailén
[Aplausos]
mientras tanto bailén continúa una
campaña más cuidadosa en medio de la
actual pandemia su equipo dijo que sólo
planeaba participar en un concierto
virtual el domingo un programa más
ligero que ha sido criticado por la
campaña de trump el equipo de bailén
respondió diciendo que estaban haciendo
una campaña segura un tema que la
candidata demócrata a la vicepresidencia
kamala harris
retomo mientras hablaba en michigan un
estado ganado por trump en 2016
ya lo nuestro
donald trump fue informado de la
naturaleza de este virus el 28 de enero
se le informó que es letal que podría
matar cinco veces más personas con la
gripe se le informó que se transmite por
el aire se le informó que puede dañar a
los niños y escondió esa información de
recker southern richard on air
information a poco más de una semana del
día de las elecciones más de 57 millones
de estadounidenses ya han emitido sus
votos anticipados ya sea por correo o en
persona un ritmo que podría llevar a la
mayor participación de votantes en más
de un siglo